I have a dream this is the musical I
thought that was singing and dancing but
in more of a 10 Things I Hate About You
kind of way not a musical musical damn
you Chris
[Music]
if you have a song that helps you cope
with anything that is either fictional
nonsense that doesn't exist or else it's
in Bach there are no other options
between this lame is and Ted to I'm
starting to think a man deciphered has a
must sing during the film clause in her
contract James Bond isn't Thomas
crowning or even Remington stealing in
this movie summer romance he'd gone long
before she realized that she was
expecting me yep I guess there's no use
in trying to track that asshole down
even though I'm baring his trouser also
better keep the child in the dark for
her whole life in the hopes that it'll
lead to an adorable musical Love
Actually meet up in the Mediterranean
someday honey honey nearly kills me oh
man a musical version of Jennifer's Body
has a lot less lesbian kissing in blood
the fact that a smoke monster doesn't
eat any of these girls while they sing
run through the woods like these girls
have never even heard of ticks rails
street are you fucking kidding me does
someone have new pictures of her or
something why is the Queen Mother
slumming in this discount grease no they
think that mom sent the invites listen
no one knows the power of boner is
better than me okay maybe Wilt
Chamberlain but the diary said they each
had one night with Donna over 20 years
ago and all of them come all the way out
here at a moment's notice not even
knowing the ultimate reason for the
invite I'm not saying it's impossible
but that's some strong boner power jump
from talking about your birth father
does singing about your honey is super
confusing and conflicting also I kind of
like this movie the first time I saw it
when it was called Muriel's full monty
Greek Wedding Crashers and I want my
father to give me away
god this movie's premise is so thin it
could have been built on an incongruous
band catalog also seriously what if one
or all these guys turn out to be
assholes couldn't Sophie an actor plan
well ahead of the actual wedding just to
make sure there weren't any issues well
no my father no you want look don't us
absolutely gonna kill you when she finds
out by the time she finds out it'll be
too late well Sophie don't get your
Drake content mixed up into this Abba
party this movie has basically couples
retreat for seniors
[Music]
Jesus I'm pretty sure 68% of this movie
is comprised of character introductions
okay it's so much about you movie with
an a-list cast is somehow written by the
backup lighting crew from Days of Our
Lives why did you wear stilettos two
Greeks for any reason man anytime this
movie gets above 300 feet it turns a
degree in screen syndrome I'm designing
a website we just want this to be the
ultimate romantic destination this was
what's supposed to be the site of
Aphrodite's found hanging on the
exposition McGee you save something for
the website
I work all night I work all day to pay
the bills I have to pay Olli I
momentarily forgot this was a musical
I'm having Meryl Streep sing basically
the same note over and over and over is
not a great way to remind me if I got me
man damn this character turn should be
sued for whiplash Donna was just saying
she didn't want to be married and she's
let the candidates that fathered her
daughter just fuck off 20 years ago so
what's the sudden fascination with
landing a shark jeez they must have
spent at least 49 percent of the total
budget on boats alone for the wedding
I'm Bill Anderson
oh man bills introduction comes with its
own zoom and enhance cliche how are the
other guys gonna compete with that I'm
not gonna lie these three are starting
to make a solid case for drinking at
11:00 a.m. are you being taken care of
this conversation just literally went
from do you need a loan - are you
getting any in seven seconds you go it's
amazing all three of these guys even
came to the wedding but the fact that
none of them right here and now says yep
I'm out of here is mathematically
impossible
I think the invites my mom doesn't know
anything and I assumed all of you had
the financial means to travel halfway
around the world to a remote location
that has to be very difficult to find
surprise all right just adorable though
promise me that you will not anybody
that
promised what is her plan here is there
any other explanation for them to all be
here that her mother will believe are
you planning to go with sheer ironic
coincidence one cannot forget everything
is the Iron Lady doing she just spied on
the three dudes she's been longing for
all in the same location on her property
and she's playing a game of peeping tom
Mamamia scene credits also I recognize
that millions of retirees enjoyed this
movie but those people are all stupid
she's definitely singing loudly enough
that the three men in the Attic should
have heard her and that's assuming they
didn't hear her footsteps on the roof
which they also definitely should hear
but whatever there's a fire within my
soul let's put Meryl Streep in this
musical it'll really give it some
gravitas okay but can she sing she's a
motive in song hmm
can she sing she's his passionate
singing is she is acting can she's
saying dog she can stay on pitch huh
sudden chorus of towns folk I remove a
thousand sins if they had a spontaneous
foursome right here and now you want me
to pitch it on that Mario Batali big
fella I'm old enough to be our mother
wait the hotel is apparently
hemorrhaging money and nothing works but
they're able to afford a full-time
bartender and an extremely well-stocked
bar
I know European priorities are different
still man I could have sworn I actually
like some of Ava's music before watching
this movie she got drunk at 11:00 a.m.
then saw three prominent ex-boyfriends
so naturally her friends try to fix all
that by getting her drunk again it's her
dad who's Sophie's dad damn Donna can't
even talk about her own daughter without
having to play the pronoun game also
though I guess since Donna still doesn't
know who the father is it'll ultimately
be Sophie's Choice but when I continue
the fucking ruse Donna knows that the
guys are here the guys know that Sophie
invited them and now Sophie knows that
Donna knows the guys are all here also
the wedding's tomorrow you don't want to
tie this loophole up with a little bit
of time to spare Sophie never finds out
incise Sophie of course already knows so
this entire movie is existing just
because people who would naturally talk
and share stories decide not to do that
I have brought this all on myself
because I was a stupid reckless little
slut actually that's kind of true but
still we don't tolerate slut-shaming
around here so all three of her best
previous lovers are in town and down to
she's acting like the world hates her
ass and needs extra convincing to even
venture out to her own daughters
bachelorette party come on I thought we
all agreed no more Merrill's jumping on
the bed
well she's fired I guess they had time
to plan this highly choreographed dance
on the trip down to the docks also
shouldn't Sophie be invited to the
dancing queen montage or who forgot
about the film's protagonist until it's
convenient to the script Riki in the
flash 1.0 we made our way along the
river and we sat down Colin Firth
singing voices like Kermit the Frog
doing a James Taylor impression it was
the edge of no regrets yeah back in
those days you could travel Europe write
some songs snuck up a few women and not
have to support them for decades good
times
no one will be seated during the young
girl in a bathing suit spends as a sexy
summer Greek day with three shirtless
old perverts portion of the movie I
wasn't jealous before we met god damn
this movie literally can't even go two
minutes without breaking into song waste
I'm not wasting them I'm pouring them
into this in writing and send aerating
which will generate views for us so I'm
actually making excellent proactive use
of the emotions you're crossing make
movie this entire sexy encounter occurs
within full view of her potential
fathers which should be gross for
everyone involved
but I'm just assuming everyone involved
has already ingested a large amount of
drugs I feel like Tom Cruise on the
plane when Rod Tidwell grabs his hand it
starts dance shouting like oh my god
discount Arsenio what have they ever
done for their daughter their own oh
these poor middle-aged moderately
attractive dudes are being tied up and
swooned over by young women seriously
who the fuck is this movie for you
should wait you should wait until she's
few drinks her first she's literally
been drunk all fucking day this is good
it's okay you love a real talent and
she's okay I don't know who my father is
oh I see these aren't the bridesmaids
from the bachelorette party
they're the screenwriters personal
convenience minions and why am I asking
this while being the featured table
dancer during an extremely loud song
while you clearly spent little money on
the green-screen and therefore minimal
money and time was spent on actual
grease
you've spent none on singing lessons I
guess all your budget went to Meryl
Streep and Pierce Brosnan in the boats
the kind of bachelor bachelorette party
combo both does this Lucille Ball eat
your heart out last night you you and
sky what's wrong I don't know what to do
you don't have to do anything this movie
is just song misunderstanding song
misunderstanding song misunderstanding
basically a lot like my sex life I have
two grown children I know something
about letting go Brosnan splaining they
seem so hard to fire god bless him but
pierce brosnan singing Sherpa sound like
a drunk David Bowie impersonator as the
first of the former flames to serenade
Donna and profess love for her it's
natural that Sam will be the one she
ends up with and probably the ultimate
father of the Sophie but this movie so
boring I bet I forget that and write us
in later about one of the other guys
probably being the true father sweet
worried about to get some John Woo gun
action no god damn it and something
happened in this fucking movie this
pedal boat is hilariously motorized
which is clear to anyone who ever
pedaled on a pedal boat but no one
involved in the making of this movie
this does your mother know that you're
out bull is the pervious song to ever /
the song was busted by Chris Hansen and
had to take a seat over there let's talk
about the blocking here people do you
think this is fifty enough or should we
be more overt man I'd get good money if
one of these characters suddenly bust
out singing Old Man River or even
something like I can only imagine losing
huh
skipper's wonderful adventure
in a strange move the Academy
reflexively showed up on set during the
scene to get Meryl her annual Oscar you
think I'm letting you down well it
depends why are you talking to the
audience or to your mom
when I got pregnant my mother told me
not to bother coming back sounds like a
bad mom for sure but I can't help but
wonder if you wanted to go back give him
the life of free love you were living in
Greece sure you were pregnant but I feel
like you suddenly calling your mommy at
that point is kind of way out of
character I'm surprised your mother
didn't reply by saying who was this
sometimes I wish that I couldn't freeze
the picture Oh God not me
I wish I could fast-forward it this
movie was nominated for best donkey in
2008 and in one of the biggest shocks of
the Year ceremony lost at Gran Torino
and Jack Nicholson said Wow down the
dusty dirt road the donkey drove Donna's
daring daughter to her draconian
dedication deed school bag in hand now
we are remembering the song she
literally just sang three movie minutes
ago I don't want to talk well certainly
don't sing then that's gonna take even
longer why not take
the loser has to fall um by the way you
know the wedding processions like
halfway up that mountain right how long
are you expecting the song to take
donnas so angry is singing this song at
Sam that it's obvious he's the one she
really loves and probably the girl's
father though this movie is so boring
I'm probably gonna forget saying that
and later will write us in about how one
of the other dudes is clearly a real
father
[Music]
these lyrics like all the songs in this
movie don't match the story or the
characters very much at all takes it all
he's had a good life sure but she bought
a fucking villa in an island and had a
daughter and drunk girlfriends and I
don't feel like their breakup left
things as lopsided as this song suggests
is what I'm saying
also whoa little make sure to stretch
before you pulled out Celine Dion fist
pump you don't want to pull a hammy
damn Donna fucking sprinted all that way
up the steep slope and is still able to
belt out this lyric who's her trainer
and what kind of steroids did they jack
her up with a trumpet a baritone and an
alto sax this is the worst wedding band
ever Stanley filming cameos for movies
MCU and beyond since 2008 so these other
two are here and just decided off-camera
not to try and walk her down the aisle
happen to that hilarious
misunderstanding subplot movie with
hundreds of men honestly for an attendee
best wedding ever but I told her rain I
couldn't marry her and I came right back
so what you're saying is this movie's
biggest misunderstandings have been
going on for decades not minutes why am
I even surprised also Sam's the first
one to speak up at the wedding which
means he's definitely going to be the
one that ends up with Donna and it's
probably also the true father of the
girl though the movie is boring enough
we can find out if you want then do it
oh my god this movie's gonna end with
everyone deciding to accept the fact
that they are all her father and never
find out for sure and I'm gonna break a
motherfucking television I made two I'll
take your third a beat I'll go a
cappella kappapa doc o'clock a trailer
everybody y'all if you doubt me I'm a
piece of YouTube critic trash I say it
proudly this movie I don't want a sin
I'm outta here tell these people
something they don't know about me I
mean last time we saw Skyy her groom he
was kind of pissed about her having made
this wedding all about finding out who
her dad was instead of her love for him
then a few scenes and now we're here and
he should be pissed right now is what
I'm saying but this movie somehow
manages to forget even more of itself
than I did I'm not entirely sure what's
happening right now damn it when will
the screenwriters stop letting their
margin notes make it into the actual
fucking script I'm a divorced man who's
loved you for 21 years
hi I'm maybe your dad and definitely
your mom and complimented your art and I
know it's your wedding day and your
wedding reception and three men just
interrupted your wedding ceremony to
argue about who was your father and who
loved your mom and who was gay but might
I trouble you by asking the favor of
letting me take the spotlight at this
moment to sing to your mom a song that
has nothing to do with you or your
husband or your marriage Thanks oh yeah
I even know what passes for a plot is
over and done with there are still a
couple of mob hits that haven't been
played also this bodes terrifically for
the sequel Oh No Sophie's leaving um I
guess I don't know why she's stealing
away under the shroud of darkness but
maybe she had a secret scroll she
to deliver to the Prime Minister of
Malaysia or something safe travels you
probably don't recognize me Phil hey
Phil and we kissed on the beach and dot
dot dot what dot dot dot that's what
they did in the olden days hey what are
some other time periods Rachel
well there's your you know yesteryear
Tommy I was a peeping
[Music]
laughs spectacles testicles wallet and
watch